MALE SPEAKER: Good
afternoon, and welcome
to Talks at Google
in Cambridge, Mass.
Today it's my great pleasure to
introduce Josh Glenn and Tony
Leone, one of the co-authors
and the designer, respectively,
of the "Unbored"
series of books.
Along with co-author
Elizabeth Foy Larson,
Josh and Tony are on a
mission to empower kids
to appreciate all
the world can offer
and to help them see how they
can add their own magic to it.
Their first book, "Unbored:
The Essential Field Guide
to Serious Fun," has been
described as "the first kids'
book to truly encourage a
hands-on approach to creating
a personally meaningful life."
Their third book will
be "Unbored Adventure."
But today they're here to talk
about their newly published
second book, "Unbored Games:
Serious Fun for Everyone."
I can't adequately
describe how amazing it is.
I've read it.
So I'll just say I wish I'd had
it when I was a kid, and had it
when my kids were young.
So please join me in
welcoming Josh and Tony.
JOSH GLENN: Thank you.
I'll let you drive the
machine, I guess, Tony.
TONY LEONE: Sure.
JOSH GLENN: So I'm Josh Glenn.
I'm born and raised here in
Boston, in Jamaica Plain.
Are you from Jamaica Plain?
Nice.
I'm from Parkside, not Pondside.
And I'm a semiotic brand
analyst in my real life.
I used to work at "The Boston
Globe" for a long time.
I was a columnist and
editor for the Ideas
section for a long time.
And Tony?
TONY LEONE: I'm Tony Leone.
I'm a graphic designer
here in the Boston area,
working-- I went to Mass Art.
I graduated from
Mass Art in '95,
have been working in
Boston ever since.
I've done a lot of work over
the years, about seven years
worth of work, with Ideo.
They're over in Central Square.
But for the past eight years
or so I've been out on my own,
running my own studio
and happily working
on the "Unbored"
books with Josh.
So I'm a more
traditional designer.
I'm not so much of
a web guy, but more
of a packaging, publications,
books, and brand designer.
JOSH GLENN: So we're going
to talk to you a little bit
about our creative process,
actually, here today.
But then we'll also talk
about our games book,
and we can even play a
game if you guys want--
if we don't run out of time.
But first we're going to talk
a little bit about-- just
because we're so fascinated
by our own process--
our process of how we made this
first book, "Unbored," which
was a bestseller back in 2012.
TONY LEONE: Josh and I, we
met back in the late '90s,
and Josh was running a zine
called "Hermenaut" at the time.
I got to know Josh because he
hired me as the art director
and designer of Issues
15 and 16 of the zine.
And what we
essentially did was we
took something that
was in a zine format
and created more of
a journal with it.
So Josh I do have a history
of working together,
and especially working
together collaboratively
on large publication projects.
We did two issues
of "Hermenaut."
And so we're just giving you
a little bit of background
as to--
JOSH GLENN: And of course,
the zine world, we were DIY.
But the ethos, the
aesthetic was supposed
to be very-- it wasn't
cool to have things that
were glossy and color covers
and nice layout and all that.
Tony and I were like,
that's not DIY at all.
DIY is just, if you
make it yourself
and no one's telling you
what to do, then it's DIY.
You can have it look
however you want.
So we took-- although
the zine started
as kind of a mimeographed
thing for 20 people,
we turned it into this
very beautiful journal that
had a circulation of
10,000 before the end.
TONY LEONE: So in
spring of 2010,
we pitched the book "Unbored."
And the idea was that it
was the best of the old
and the best of the new.
Josh, I'll let you
take this part of it.
JOSH GLENN: Yeah, so
there was this book that
was very popular around that
time, "The Dangerous Book
for Boys" that was
very nostalgic.
And I had-- my kids
at that time were--
my two sons were age 12 and 10.
And they had been
given, I think,
three copies of that
book by usually,
like, grandparents
or aunts or uncles,
or other people who were
kind of worried about how
kids are growing up these days.
They felt like, supposedly
kids these days they
spend all their time on
TV or on screens or video
games, the Internet,
they don't go outside.
Parents overparent
and they're worried
about letting their
kids run around outside
and be in the woods.
And there was a lot of
nostalgia for the good old days
of childhood.
So "The Dangerous Book for
Boys" was a huge publishing
phenomenon.
And what frustrated me and Tony
and our co-author Elizabeth
Larson, who couldn't be
here because she lives
in Minneapolis-- what frustrated
us about books like that
and a lot of books
that imitate it
that have come out since
then is that they're just
a nostalgia trip.
They're very afraid
of the present, and so
their reaction to
the present-- not
that their criticism of the
present is wrong, necessarily,
but the reaction was to
retreat into the past,
into this nostalgic idea of
how childhood used to be.
And we wanted books
for our kids that
were about now, that
were about-- that
weren't hypocritical.
And we use the computer.
We let our kids
use the computer.
We like games, video games.
So we wanted books
that would have
some of that good
old-fashioned kind
of outdoor, no-screen,
low-tech activities for kids.
We wanted it to
be realistic, too,
and have a book that would
be a way of exploring
the world together
with our kids.
And that book
didn't really exist.
So we pitched this best of
the old, best of the new idea
to Bloomsbury.
TONY LEONE: And so in
order to pitch the book,
Josh wrote a couple
of articles and I
designed some very
loose, rough spreads
of what it might look like.
So we chose the game Foursquare.
So Josh wrote an article
about Foursquare--
JOSH GLENN: As an example
of an old-fashioned game
that doesn't require any
technology or screens.
TONY LEONE: Exactly.
And then we did
Foursquare, the app.
JOSH GLENN: Which my kids and
I used, even though at the time
it was really sort of a
way for people in their 20s
to find their friends and
to brag about how many bars
they'd been to that
night or whatever.
My kids and I used
Foursquare all the time
because it was a way to force
us out of our normal routines.
So if we were in Brookline
and dropping one of my kids
off at his bass lesson
and my other son
I had an hour to kill,
we would use Foursquare
and say, hey, no one
checked into this graveyard.
Let's go into the graveyard
and check in there.
So we turned it into a fun way
for me and an eight-year-old
to spend time together
exploring the world
and using an app to do it.
So to us that doesn't
seem like a bad thing.
It seemed like a good thing.
TONY LEONE: And just
to say a little bit
about the design of the spreads,
the editor we were working
with at Bloomsbury, he
called us pretty much about,
I would say about two
days before our meeting,
and he said, oh,
it would be great
if you had some visuals to
come along with your pitch.
So we hurriedly
put these together.
And it really raised
a lot of questions
as to what this book
should look like.
And we'll talk a little
more about that in a bit.
So we pitched the book.
We got a contract that summer.
And as I typically start with
any large-scale design project,
and Josh does in his work,
we did a lot of research.
I spent a good several weeks
researching the market segment
of kids and family
activity books.
And I scoured the
market, and I just
collected images and
spreads from all the books.
And very quickly a
series of themes came up.
So we broke it out
into nostalgic.
So this is "The
Dangerous Book for Boys,"
"The Daring Book for Girls,"
the "Field and Forest"--
the "Handy" books, which
is a pretty famous series.
Another theme emerged, which
was appropriated or retro.
So there's the "Popular
Mechanics," you know,
the boy scientist,
the girl mechanic.
"The Worst Case
Scenario" handbooks,
where they're meant to
look like survival guides.
"The Zombie Survival Guide."
Another style that
came up was, for lack
of a better word, a styled
graphic illustration,
where they were
designed or created
by designers who are half
designer and half Illustrator,
and they kind of
created their own look,
but that had a very
computer-centric sort
of illustration style.
Eclectic collage.
This is very much the
DK books for kids.
DK Publish has mastered
this look for kids.
So we knew right away we wanted
to maybe do some of this,
but we didn't want to be
just another DK type of book.
Again, they master it, so we
found a lot of that stuff.
Another feature that came
up was this contemporary,
what I call
contemporary technical.
And this is very
much like the, you're
on a flight in the airplane in
there's sort of the emergency
exit pamphlet in the airplane.
It's that type of illustration.
And then certainly
just modern design,
things that aren't necessarily
a particular style,
but just created by designers,
like the ReadyMade books
and the ReadyMade
magazines, great.
Ellen Lupton's books
for kids are great.
And here's a series
more. "The Mini Weapons
of Mass Destruction"
are great books.
"Geek Dads," and certainly
"Make" magazine as well.
And then lastly,
illustrated characters.
You know, the sort of classic
way to reach out to kids
is through some sort of
cartoon-like character
or characters that
sort of run you
through either a
lesson or an activity.
Here's some more here. "The
Middle School Confidential."
And then there's a lot of
stuff like the "Oh, Yikes!"
books, stuff that's cartoony
or meant to be gross or silly.
That was another theme
that started to emerge.
And lastly, these are
illustrated character books,
but yet they're
more stuff almost
you would see in your high
school guidance counselor's
office or a doctor's
office or something.
You know, "Boy's Guide
to Becoming a Teen."
We knew right away this is
not where we wanted to be.
JOSH GLENN: So to be clear,
those are all good books
that we looked at, and they're
all perfectly good illustration
styles.
So our question is,
what do we want--
what's right for our book?
And one thing I love
about working with Tony
is, he and I are both very
left-brained and right-brained.
So we're very creative
and imaginative,
but we're also very analytical
and like to do our research.
In fact, Tony's
wife complains to me
sometimes that when
they frame a picture
it takes like six months to
get it hung up on the wall,
because Tony's like thinking,
planning each wall, studying.
But I like that.
So we did a lot of research.
And then I decided to
use some of the tools I
use in my work as a
semiotic brand analyst
to look at the stimulus, the
data that Tony had collected.
So this is the next
step that we took.
So what I do in my work
is, I use the tools
of semiotic analysis to surface
critical insights for marketers
and branders and
organizations, anybody
who has a brand that they're
trying to get out there,
to help them understand the
context in which they're
operating.
There's a saying in marketing--
I'm not actually in marketing,
but I consult to
marketers-- that it doesn't
matter what your
brand communicates.
What matters is what
the consumer hears,
because there's a gap
between what you say
and what they hear.
And that gap is
filled with culture.
There's all this
unspoken network
of codes and
assumptions and ways
of thinking that affect
and influence and drive
our understanding and our
interpretation of everything
that is sent to us, whether it's
from culture or from marketing.
So what I do in my work is do a
deep dive into a category, all
the images and
visuals, whether it's
the beer category or
automotive, or more
like a cultural territory
like Britishness or luxury.
And I surface all these
codes and then map them,
trying to find the
deep underlying themes
of that category.
And then that kind of
becomes a strategic tool
that I can hand over to the
marketing people or the brand
stakeholders, and
they can kind of
have a sense of where
they want to operate
and how they can operate.
So I said, well,
why don't I just use
that same tool for Tony's work?
So we did.
So one big, underlying, binary
opposition that we determined
was in the world of
kids' books at that time
that we did the study was a big
opposition between silly books
and earnest books.
So on the one hand
there was books
that are very much like for
kids only, like the "Oh, Yuck!"
type of books, boys only.
Like parents not
invited basically
was the message of
these kind of books.
It's the kind of thing you
would give to your kids
and hopefully they
would leave you alone
for a while, which was obviously
not what we wanted to do.
We wanted a project for kids
that you could do with parents.
The other end of
that spectrum was
kind of earnest,
very earnest books
that were kind of
for parents, and they
were sort of parenting guides
and not that fun for the kids.
And somewhere
right in the center
is probably a sweet spot.
Unfortunately, as you're
approaching the center,
if you don't hit that
sweet spot exactly,
it can feel very phony and
contrived on the way in there,
we discovered.
And then the other
big continuum is
between permissive
and authoritarian.
This is more about
parenting styles.
So in the world of parenting,
as any of you who are parents
know, probably, the
three parenting styles
that you hear people talk
about are permissive,
where you let your kids
do whatever they want,
authoritarian, where
you're authoritarian
and you're cracking the whip.
And then authoritative is
the sort of in-between place
where you're not letting
your kids run wild,
you're not cracking
the whip, you're
trying to find a balance
between those two things.
And again, there's
a lot of books
that are about sort of--
because there was kind
of a backlash going on at that
time against overparenting
and helicopter parenting,
quite a lot of books that
were sort of anti-authoritarian.
And there was a lot of
books that are very,
like, these old boy scientist
books that were getting
reissued and stuff that
are sort of, here's
how to do cool
projects but you have
to follow these rules exactly.
There's no room for wiggle room.
And there are some books in the
middle like "Make" magazine,
"DIY Kids," that
we felt were sort
of hitting that sweet spot
between the two, where it's fun
and you can kind of--
there's guidelines,
but you don't have to
follow them exactly,
and there's room for
experimentation and play.
So in my world, I put the two
codes, two binary opposites
together, and you get
a four-quadrant map.
So where silly meets
authoritarian we're calling it
the cajoling section
on the bottom left.
And these are kids'
books that were
sort of fun teacher, the camp
counselor, maybe a cool cousin
at best.
So the green ones that are kind
of-- that are farthest out--
are sort of lame category,
or extreme versions
of that quadrant.
The yellow codes that
you're seeing here
are kind of the middle
of the row, which
can seem a little
phony and contrived.
And the blue ones seemed
pretty cool to us.
So at best, in the
cajoling quadrant,
you had like a
cool older cousin.
I had cool older cousins
in the '70s who, you know,
they're cooler than your
teacher or a camp counselor.
They're showing you something
that's maybe kind of dangerous
that parents wouldn't
let you do normally.
It's exciting.
But they may be getting you
out of your comfort zone,
which is a good thing.
TONY LEONE: One thing
we did here, too,
is we assigned personas to
some of these, on the map
here as well.
And it helps from
a design standpoint
because once we start
going into design
it starts to give a sense as
to, who are we trying to target
and who is it
being designed for?
So to apply personas
here is a nice tool
in the design process.
JOSH GLENN: So in the top left
where permissive meets silly,
this is the wacky quadrant.
And it's quite a popular
quadrant for kids' books.
We were saying the worst of
it is like the creepy uncle.
A book like "Oh,
Yuck!" is something
that maybe an uncle
with bad boundaries
would give to your
kid, and you'd kind of
be bummed out that he had
given that to your kid.
Kitsch is somewhere
in the middle.
And then the kooky aunt.
We think that's a really good
thing, to be a kooky aunt.
So that's a good
version of wacky.
Then in the top right, where
permissive meets earnest.
This is like sherpa parenting,
as people were calling it back
then.
So it's sort of hippie
parents, slacker moms, low key.
And we felt like maybe there
was a white space there
or something.
There wasn't really a cool
version of that quadrant yet.
And then authoritarian
meets earnest.
We called this the
particular quadrant.
This is like fussy grandparents,
helicopter parents,
at best, maybe with the
grandparents, are geeky
and crafty parents, like Mark
Frauenfelder from "Make" doing
stuff with his daughter
sort of would fit there.
So that gives us a map.
Then we layered Tony's
research on top of that map,
and we decided that
there was an opportunity
to do something that
fit with our values
as parents and as
people who wanted
to do a book that was different.
And it also-- there
was an opportunity
that no one else was doing
something in the space.
It's sort of a little more
earnest than the kooky aunt,
a little more permissive,
maybe, than the geeky
and crafty parents.
It's a little
easier stuff to do.
You don't have to follow
all these rules exactly.
So it's maybe a little
bit on the serious side,
but not all the way to
earnest, and a little bit
on the permissive side, but
sort of fun authoritative,
but not all the way
towards permissive.
So we decided to take our
inspiration from the books that
were kind of right
around that area.
So this was our opportunity.
This was all-- we're
making it sound like we
did this kind of like
creepy adult coming in
from the outside and
studying the kids' category.
But it was also-- the idea was
to try to articulate and put
language and visuals to our
own parenting philosophy
and what we wanted
this book to be.
So then the design
codes we mapped on here.
Do you want to talk
about this, Tony?
TONY LEONE: Sure.
Here what we're
able to do is, as we
mapped the imagery,
images of the books
from my research
on here, we were
able to take the themes
that emerged and map
the themes on here as well, just
to help further articulate it.
So around our sweet
spot, we thought maybe
some contemporary
technical, certainly
contemporary modern,
little bit of nostalgia,
and the idea of something
being undesigned.
It certainly is
designed, but it's not--
there's a certain simplicity
to it that lends itself--
JOSH GLENN: Our big example
of that was the "Whole Earth
Catalog," like '70s stuff that
we grew up with, like the Zoom
"Do" books in the '70s and
"The Whole Earth Catalog."
They are designed, but
they look undesigned.
They look kind of
pasted down on purpose.
TONY LEONE: So from there
we went into inspiration.
Where do we take
all this research?
Where we take the semiotic
analysis, and what's
going to inspire us visually
against all these codes?
So again, it's
pretty much what I
do with any large-scale
design project.
So we looked at
doodle-like-- we want
the doodle-like
illustration, the idea being
that we would hire
professional illustrators
and it would certainly be
done in a professional way,
but it would have a much
more approachable look,
almost as if a kid
could have drawn it.
My son can't draw anything
quite as cool as this,
but he could certainly
aspire to it.
Certainly the idea of
scrapbooks and collages.
These are just images I
found around the Internet
and through research of just
something that might inspire
color or a juxtaposition
of imagery.
Certainly hand-drawn
typographic textures
with the idea of
a DIY, something
that had the maker's
hand involved
in some of the
typography might be nice.
Cool books, DIY feel, and
again, the creator's hand.
So this really
started to lead us
down a trail of what we
wanted our illustration
style to look like.
If you remember, in the
first spreads we put together
for the pitch, it had a very
technical sort of feel to it.
But after our research
in the semiotic analysis,
we decided we wanted something
very much with a hand quality
feel to it.
So that led us to two
illustrators, the first
being Mister Reusch.
His actual name is Mark Reusch,
but his illustration name
is Mister Reusch.
The interesting thing
about the two illustrators
we brought on to the
project is neither of them
have the style that you
currently see in the book.
So Mark's style, it's very
hand-drawn but very painterly.
He tends to paint a
lot of his work, even
his black and white
work at the bottom.
JOSH GLENN: He's
done a lot of work
for video games, snowboards.
TONY LEONE: Yeah.
Burton Snowboards--
JOSH GLENN: Rock Band.
TONY LEONE: --shoes.
I think he's done a little
bit of work for Nike.
But it's very painterly style.
So he's someone I
know personally,
so I asked him if-- can you
do something more sketchy.
So we gave each of the
illustrators an assignment
and it was like, draw some
objects, musical instruments,
sewing supplies.
We knew some of
these things were
going to be appearing
in the book,
sewing supplies and
camping equipment.
So Mark did a great job.
JOSH GLENN: And poor Mark had
just broken his wrist sledding
right when Tony was
asking him to do this,
and he didn't want to tell us.
TONY LEONE: Yeah,
he didn't tell us
he had broken his
right hand, and so he
drew all these
with his left hand.
And he drew them
really big because he
could have more control
with his left hand,
and he scanned them
and shrunk them.
JOSH GLENN: And he didn't tell
us until like a year later.
TONY LEONE: Yeah.
We didn't find out
until a year later.
He really wanted the project.
Heather is another-- we all
knew each other from back
in the Mass Arts days.
I do want to say I didn't
just go to my friends
for this project.
We actually did
research, and I contacted
some pretty well-known
illustrators in New York.
And after looking at these
other illustrators' work
I was like, I
really think people
I know can actually do
what we're looking for.
So that's why I said we more
or less gave them a test.
Heather's more of a fine
artist and an art educator.
She teaches art in the
Springfield, Mass high school
system.
But she-- I knew her
from back at Mass Art.
I knew she could do
what we're looking for.
So these are some
of her sketchbooks.
These are some-- she does
these beautiful giant cut-paper
illustrations that are
more or less installations.
This is some of her
black and white work.
We gave her the same test,
so she drew some camping
equipment, some sewing
supplies, and she drew actually
some Foursquare stuff for us.
So after all this, we
had gotten the contract.
And we needed to get--
JOSH GLENN: Bloomsbury's
the publisher.
TONY LEONE: Bloomsbury's
So we needed to get
buy-in by Bloomsbury
for the design of the book.
So we put together
some rough spreads
using Heather's and Mark's work.
JOSH GLENN: We should
whip through this part.
We want to get to games.
TONY LEONE: So Bloomsbury
gave us the go.
They gave us the thumbs
up, they said go for it.
Except for the cover.
In the world of
books, the covers,
more than anything
else, is dictated
by the marketing department.
So we shifted from
working with our editor
to working with the team in
marketing and our editor.
So the cover--
JOSH GLENN: Long,
painful process.
TONY LEONE: It was a
long, painful process.
I'll just go through quickly
all the iterations of the cover.
JOSH GLENN: And the
marketing department
also gets to decide
the title of the book.
This is our working title.
TONY LEONE: This is
our working title.
JOSH GLENN: Go back to that one.
Every now and then
they would say,
try something with a
circle, like a maze.
TONY LEONE: So a
maze and a circle.
JOSH GLENN: We tried
everything they told us.
I love all these
covers, by the way.
TONY LEONE: Any one of these
would have made a great cover.
We ended on this one, and
the editor loved this one,
though at that point he said,
can you send me some titles.
So after a long
iteration of covers, then
he wanted to look at titles.
We came up with a lot of
names, a lot of names.
He said more better.
And he came at us with
"The Young Kicker's Guide
to the Sweet Life."
JOSH GLENN: We like to
remember that because we
like to make fun of
him for saying that.
TONY LEONE: It's
still on our list
to make shirts that
say The Young Kicker's
Guide to the Sweet Life.
So we went back with more names.
And "Freestyle," "The Backpack
Rebellion," "Unbored,"
and "The Y.E.A.H. Manifesto"
started to emerge.
JOSH GLENN: And "Unbored"
was almost like a joke name
at that point in this
long list of names.
But we liked it because
it was kind of punk rock.
Like "unsane" or something.
TONY LEONE: Or "the unwound."
So we tried some of the covers
in the style that we liked.
JOSH GLENN: This was so cool.
We should have done this one.
TONY LEONE: Exactly.
JOSH GLENN: Go back to that one.
"The Y.E.A.H. Manifesto."
Isn't that a good
name for a book?
We were like making up
what Y.E.A.H. stood for,
like young,
entrepreneurial, whatever.
They said no.
TONY LEONE: So you know,
we got pretty close here.
Tried some different treatments.
And here we got really close.
And finally we got a real book.
JOSH GLENN: Yeah.
TONY LEONE: This is the book.
JOSH GLENN: Has a nice
holographic-- what's it called?
Foil.
TONY LEONE: Holographic foil.
You have to lend some color.
And here's some
spreads from the book.
We hired a lettering
Illustrator named Chris Piascik.
He lives in Western Mass.
Great guy.
He was a designer who's now--
all he does is hand lettering,
so is more or less a
hand-letterer Illustrator
these days.
But he did all our
divider pages for us.
So that's that hand-drawn
typography from our inspiration
slides.
Some of Mark's illustrations
about how to rock out,
written by someone who runs
a rock school for kids.
"Soak and Destroy," by John
Edgar Park, "Make" magazine.
An article on
young adult novels.
There's a series of nice
spreads in the large book,
the first book, "Unbored,"
that are timelines.
So I had this idea for this one.
It was one of our first
ideas for illustration
to do a timeline as if you're
standing on your back pocket
porch looking across
a series of backyards,
and all the objects that
are featured in the timeline
show up, and kids and families
are playing in the backyard.
Article "Step Up"
with Rebecca Walker.
Art of how to make zines.
More Chris Piascik work
just because it's so great.
And a beautiful
illustration by Heather
here of a Chinese
New Year dragon.
Thank you.
JOSH GLENN: So Tony doesn't
like to toot his own horn,
but he won three prestigious
design awards for this book.
So all that research paid off.
And the book sold
really well, and so
they asked us to do a series of
spinoffs, smaller paperbacks,
that were actually more like
what we originally conceived
of, as a field guide, like
something you actually take out
with you, kind of
waterproof, you
could have it in
your pocket, almost.
And we decided to start
with one on games,
because especially in my
case-- my kids are now older.
My kids were 12 and
10 when I started,
and they're now 16 and 14.
And they're getting out of
this age range of these books.
These books are sort of
eight- to 12-year-olds.
But games are one thing
that my kids will still
do with me any time.
So we thought the games
is a good family activity
book to do.
We're going to do
another one on adventure.
We're not sure after that.
So in spirit of the
games book, does anyone
want to play one of our games?
Let's play a little
game while we still
have a few more minutes.
It's a-- I'm like
Jane McGonigal.
I make everyone play a game.
It's a low-tech parlor game
called Telephone Pictionary.
So it's like the
game Telephone, where
as you whisper a word to someone
and it goes along the line,
it gets more and more-- it
gets farther and farther
away for what it started.
And it's like Pictionary,
in which you're
drawing a picture of something
that someone else is trying
to communicate to you,
but you may not always
know exactly what that is.
So the way this game works
is that the first person
will write a sentence here,
or some kind of phrase.
It could be like, the
cat walked on the moon.
Grandma was roller skating.
Just something like that.
You hand that pad
to somebody else.
They turn the page and they draw
a picture of what you said, OK?
So it's a sentence
and then a picture.
You then hand the
picture to somebody else.
They don't know what
the first sentence was.
All they can see
is your picture.
So they then turn the
page and write a sentence
based on what they think the
picture is, and so forth.
So when you get handed a pad,
if it's got a sentence here,
you do a picture.
If it's got a picture
here, you do a sentence.
And the first person who gets
the pad has to write a phrase.
Any questions?
All right, I'm going to pass
out three different ones.
TONY LEONE: Josh, I
can pass them this way.
JOSH GLENN: OK.
TONY LEONE: Do
you have a marker?
JOSH GLENN: You get to start.
TONY LEONE: You want to go?
JOSH GLENN: All right.
Parlor games-- while
you guys are starting,
I'll talk a little
bit about the game.
TONY LEONE: Starts
with a sentence,
some sort of statement.
JOSH GLENN: Yeah, so some
kind of evocative phrase
or sentence, short, that can
get someone to draw a picture.
So the games book picks up
on some of the-- obviously
looks a lot like
the "Unbored" book,
and it picks up on some of
the same kind of rubrics
that we developed.
Like we have Best Ever lists,
like our favorite novels,
our favorite board games.
For this one we have so
many favorite board games
we broke it into favorite
cooperative board
games, favorite quick board
games, favorite reboots
of board games.
We have a lot of-- I think
maybe 75 or 80 game instructions
in here.
And again, we try not
to be too instructive,
so we sort of give guidelines
for how to play the game.
And then we really
encourage-- we usually
have a little sidebar that
has some hacks of the game,
and then we encourage the
kids and their parents
to invent their own
hacks for the games.
And we have comics that tell
the history of various things.
So here's a history of
board games told in comics.
We have how to, sort of
"Make" magazine-style how
to articles with photos.
So there's just so much
in these little books.
And I think it took
us like a year to do.
Here's a duct tape, a
game out of duck tape.
Here's a rocket-launching game
that my brother-in-law, who
teaches math in the
Boston public schools,
uses to teach angles.
They have to make a very
dangerous, actually,
launch out of PVC
pipe, which we thought
was safe because he had a book
from NASA about how to do it.
But after this book
came out we realized
that NASA has
recalled that book.
Geo games, you know,
GPS-type games, geocaching.
I think there's even a Google
Earth game section in here.
So one thing we like
about parlor games, which
is the game that we're
passing around now,
is that parlor games just
inherently brings the family
together because you're all
facing each other in a circle.
You're not distracted
by any screens.
You're not even
looking at a board.
Oftentimes there's
no equipment at all,
or maybe just a pencil
and a piece of paper.
There's a bunch in here that
our families like to play.
And the nice thing
about family game night
is that it's just an
amazing way for a family
to affirm they all
like each other,
because you don't have to
do it, you know what I mean?
There's no reason to
do a family game night.
It's not helpful,
it's not productive,
it's not doing chores,
not creating something.
It's just having fun
together on a school night.
And that's really
nice, actually.
It's a nice little break to have
with your family once in awhile
to make that happen.
How are we doing on the pads?
All right.
Let's let them go
a little farther.
TONY LEONE: One thing I just
wanted to add about our books
as well is that Josh and I
both came out of the zine world
from the '90s.
I worked on a punk
zine in the early '90s,
and we're both out of
the punk and hardcore
scene from the '80s.
So our book, from
the beginning, we
wanted it to have this sort
of eclectic feel, where
it has excerpts from old books.
And as Josh was saying, it's got
game theory, game activities.
So it was designed
to be simple enough
to incorporate all of these sort
of divergent pieces of content.
JOSH GLENN: Yeah.
It ended up being actually quite
complex sort of structurally,
the book, because it's--
and the way Tony finally--
on the first book, as we finally
got to the end of the finish
line there, was the idea ended
up being kind of, it's supposed
to look like an old-fashioned
manual of how to do stuff.
But then somebody's hacked
it by scribbling notes on it.
TONY LEONE: Sort
of redrawing it.
JOSH GLENN: Redrawing it.
And crossing things
out, and ripping
things out of other pages
and sticking them in
like you might do with a
cookbook, like recipes.
So there's a lot of
things that look taped in
or that are done on torn
paper or graph paper.
TONY LEONE: Yeah, there's a lot
of torn paper texture in there.
JOSH GLENN: So
yeah, we're hoping
at sort of a subliminal
level, again,
kids'll get the
idea that what we're
trying to teach
with these books is
DIY, the same thing
that Tony and I did back
when we met in the '90s.
Like doing it yourself is much
more fun than buying something
that's already made for you.
And even if it doesn't look
as good or perfect as the sort
of fancy finished product
that you'd buy, that's fine.
That's actually part
of the charm of it,
is that you made it,
and all the rough edges
are part of what you
like so much about it.
So we wanted the book, even
though it's a beautiful book,
to have some kind of that
rough-edged look going
on inside of it.
Let's take questions now
while we're doing this.
JP.
AUDIENCE: Should I get up?
JOSH GLENN: Oh, sure.
AUDIENCE: All right.
So I guess I have two questions.
You could choose
whichever one you want.
First one is, you obviously
spent a lot of time thinking
about the design,
not just the package,
but just the brand,
everything, the whole feel.
But the content, obviously,
is really important.
Did you just take
things from your life?
Did you source?
Did you go online and
did you crowdsource it?
Did you test everything?
Obviously the content kind
of makes or breaks it.
And then the other question
is kind of content-based.
You have all these people
doing-- like Ze Frank or Rainn
Wilson doing these like,
put a challenge out online,
and all of our people go
out and dress your vacuum up
like your mom, take
a photo, and then
you have this resource of 10,000
photos of this funny thing.
Did you guys-- you obviously
went for the book format.
Are you doing-- do you know
what's happening in the wild,
or do you care?
Or are you getting
people to send things in
or to contribute back?
Or is it just like,
this is for your world,
and you go and use
it as you wish?
JOSH GLENN: Yeah.
Well, to take the
second question first,
we would love to have a
super robust online community
like that, where we
could put out a challenge
and have people send it in.
And we've had a
little bit of success
with that through our website.
However, because we're working
with a big corporate publisher,
and because they're
very, very worried
about an unmonitored space where
children would be interacting
with adults, there's a
lot of worries about that.
So we kind of can't do
that on our website.
We're trying to be
careful about that.
So what we do is, in our
books and on our website--
and actually we're
producing-- are we
allowed to talk about
what we're doing?
TONY LEONE: I think so.
We're in the process
of producing two toy
kits at the moment.
JOSH GLENN: Yeah.
Those will be out next year.
And what we're doing
is basically saying,
we would love to
see what you made.
Post it online with
the following hashtag.
But we're not saying, post it
to our site or send it to us.
Wherever you put
it, we'll find it.
So yes, that's answer to that.
Then as far as the
content goes, the idea
was partly to kind of
capture all the fun
that we were having as
parenting, me and Elizabeth
and Tony, with our
kids at that time.
So a lot of this is
basically from our own lives,
and yes, we did
all the activities
that are in the book.
We tested them all with
our kids or with our kids'
friends or our
nieces and nephews.
And then we were also
kind of harvesting
our own memories of childhood.
So we were getting a little
bit into that kind of dangerous
"book for boys" sort of
nostalgia for when we were kids
and our parents weren't
paying any attention to us,
and we were running wild
in the woods all summer.
So to capture a lot
of that stuff too.
And then, Elizabeth and
I are both very nerdy
researcher-type people, too.
So there was quite a bit of
looking up historical games
and reading books about
games in the 1930s
and testing with our kids.
So that was how we
did the content.
TONY LEONE: And
we did invite in--
or Josh and Elizabeth did
through their own connections--
experts in certain areas.
Like John Edgar Park
did two articles,
and he's a contributor to "Make"
Magazine, and Rebecca Walker.
So there's experts
in their own field.
JOSH GLENN: But we ended up
having, like, 30 contributors.
I didn't even mention that.
Like we wanted to do a thing
on citizen science projects.
So we got a scientist to write
about all her favorite citizen
science projects.
So yeah, we had a knitting
expert, or someone
who has a website
about knitting,
do a whole project on
knitting for the kids.
In this book we only
have four of those,
but we had a lot in the first
book, a lot of outside experts.
All right, let's bring up those
pads and show what we have.
Thank you.
Cool.
Thanks.
TONY LEONE: One
more coming, Josh.
JOSH GLENN: We can start.
She won-- I'm not going
to pre-screen these,
so hopefully it's all PG.
She wondered how--
what's this say?--
hairy it could possibly be.
Oh, rain, does this say?
I think the person
read it as rain,
so here's a person wondering
how rainy it could possibly be.
And that got turned into
rain or shine-- that
makes sense-- which got turned
into rain or shine, image.
Oh, that person got it.
Rain or shine.
How many ways can you
show rain or shine?
Is it raining or
sunny turned into--
I think that's
where we ended up.
So this started
with, she wondered
how hairy it could possibly be.
TONY LEONE: So here we've got
the cat jumped over the igloo.
Great drawing of a cat
jumping over an igloo.
You guys are good
illustrators, by the way.
We do these events
with kids, and you
get these little tiny
stick figure illustrations.
The cat jumped over the igloo.
And another great
illustration of a cat
jumping over the igloo.
JOSH GLENN: Yeah, people
are good at kind of--
TONY LEONE: This one
stayed on course.
JOSH GLENN: Here the
old man struggled
to push his shopping cart.
OK.
Sad, frowny guy with sort of
a hunchback pushing a shopping
cart.
Help, I've fallen,and my
bread stick is escaping.
OK.
So this shows somebody's
falling off a ladder,
and there's a bread stick with
arms and legs running away.
TONY LEONE: That's great.
I like the bread stick.
JOSH GLENN: A pretzel saw
a boy fall off a ladder.
Makes sense.
And there it is.
Pretzel looking at the
boy-- a pretzel with eyes,
looking at the boy,
holding up a ladder.
So obviously this
can go on and on.
Sometimes when I go to
large family gatherings,
we'll get a couple of these
pads going and everyone sitting
in a circle.
And while we're talking
about something else
or even eating dinner
you can kind of
pass these around
the circle, and it
has hilarity at the end,
especially when kids
are drawing the pictures.
All right that's
our presentation.
I think we just made
it under the wire.
Thanks, everybody.
And questions?
TONY LEONE: Any other questions?
JOSH GLENN: OK.
Thank you very much.
TONY LEONE: Thank you.